america's top diplomat anthony blinken
is in geneva to meet with russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov for make
or break talks that could determine war
or peace in europe
on thursday blinken was in berlin where
he held talks with german foreign
minister annalina bierbach and their
british and french counterparts a
meeting meant to show a united front and
clear up any misunderstanding about
western unity regarding russian
aggression against ukraine
the stakes are high
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
landing in berlin to try and rally
america's allies and prevent a war
unity is the main goal here blinken and
his german french and british
counterparts discuss the intense fears
that russia may soon invade ukraine
their focus how to credibly deter moscow
with warnings of what could follow
even as we're relentless in pursuing
this diplomatic path
we'll continue to make very clear that
if moscow chooses the path of further
aggression
we will impose swift and massive costs
we urgently call on russia to take steps
towards the escalation
any further aggression would have
serious
but consequences by the us president a
day earlier have raised questions about
whether those consequences really do
apply to any act of aggression
russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having to
fight about what to do and not do etc
but if they actually do what they're
capable of doing with the force of mass
on the border it is going to be a
disaster for russia
the white house later tried to clarify
insisting that the west would react come
what may but the issue has highlighted
questions over what level of aggression
would trigger what kind of response the
us has made it clear that it would
expect berlin to target the
controversial nordstream 2 pipeline
which links germany to russian gas
it's also worth noting that gas is not
flowing through nordstrom 2 yet which
means that the pipeline is leveraged
for germany the united states and our
allies not russia
for now though there's another round of
diplomacy coming up anthony blinken will
meet his russian counterpart in geneva
on friday seen as one of the last
chances to find a way of avoiding war
and my colleague alexander farnam is in
geneva to follow those talks for us
if few ten stays there between the us
and russia what are we expecting from
from today's meeting
i would say that the expectations are
not very high here in geneva on this
very stormy windy day and you as
secretary of state lincoln told the
german press that he is not expecting
any breakthroughs that it's more about
taking stock of
where we stand right now and whether a
diplomatic solution to the crisis can be
found and what we have heard from the
washrooms they are also quite
pessimistic and they are continuing with
their very aggressive rhetoric
and there are demanding written
guarantees from the u.s and from nato
and u.s secretary of state lincoln has
already said that the u.s is so far not
prepared to give them a written response
lincoln has met with his eu counterparts
or at least some of his eu counterparts
this week do you think is there really a
united front towards russia
well i think that they are united in
what they are ready to do if there will
be a russian invasion of ukraine and
they have made clear that they will be
massive and severe consequences however
we also have to say and that is
something uh what in
the you asked president joe biden has
admitted
in a press conference that they are not
so united when we speak about to what
extent they are ready to impose
political and economic sanctions with
some european allies like germany or
france for example who have been in the
past quite reluctant of uh
of inflicting too much pain on russia
well russian troops uh have gathered
near the ukrainian border how have nato
allies responded so far
so far they have made it clear that they
are siding with ukraine and they are
ready to support ukraine uh the baltic
states for example they want to provide
ukraine with
anti-tank
missiles and with the stinger
air defense systems and weapons that
they got from the us and the u.s has
improved that and
washington wants to increase its
military assistance
assistance to ukraine uh and uh as you
can see
there is a strong support for ukraine in
this crisis
fernando there
joining us from geneva thank you
alexander
well dw political correspondent hans
brown is following this story for us
hans what do you make of that meeting
did the result
did it result in the show of unity that
the western allies were hoping for
yes it certainly was a show of unity the
question is to what extent the unity is
real behind the scenes as it were in the
discussions that were going on and one
has to say that there too
the diplomacy that has been going on in
recent days and weeks
a lot of it behind the scenes has
resulted in
more agreement i think on the side of
the one we'll call it western allies
maybe um
the german foreign minister emphasized
all the groups that are involved in this
the g7 uh the european union and also
nato that all of these were involved so
we're talking about dozens of countries
and that obviously is a stiff
ask to try and coordinate all the
different opinions amongst all of those
countries but i think what is clear now
is that
negotiations with russia
are uh on the
are on the most important at the moment
but the responses that might result from
russian aggression are being formulated
in the background although not much
about that is
being said in the open at the moment
uh hans uh blinken said in in in that
report interestingly that the north
stream two pipeline uh was leveraged in
favor of germany and its allies meaning
that germany could still refuse the
final go ahead to open the taps on the
pipeline is it likely the german
government
would do that
in the event of a russian invasion
yes that is one of the possible
responses of that in fact has been
discussed openly quite extensively
because it has been particularly
controversial the german government has
said for quite a long time that this
pipeline is a project that
is run by private companies it's a
commercial venture and that it did not
want in wanting to
involve this in the whole dispute but
most recently this week the german
chancellor olaf schultz has implied that
the pipeline will in fact become part of
the dealing with russia if aggression
should happen in ukraine so there's been
some movement it's some significant
movement on that germany is
weakening its pose and is
giving in basically to united states
demands hans brunt there for us thank
you hans